foreign
fast-paced business World a business
analyst is like a superhero for a
company they identify opportunities
streamline processes mitigate risks
facilitate communication and support
decision making with their ability to
analyze data and identify Trends they
help companies stay ahead of the
competition they also act as a bridge
between departments ensuring everyone is
on the same page think of them as the
glue that holds a company together
ensuring projects are completed on time
and within budget companies would
struggle to make strategic decisions in
weight and grow without them because of
such an important and demanding role
business analyst earns around 80 000 on
average so if you want to become a
business analyst this video will provide
you essential tips and guidance hey
everyone and welcome back to Simply
learn we are back with an exciting video
on how to become a business analyst but
first let me ask you a question which of
the following is not a responsibility of
a business analyst and your options are
First Option writing code second option
Gathering and documenting requirements
third option analyzing business
processes fourth fascinating
communication between stakeholders you
can drop your answers in the comment
section below and get a hurt from Simply
nerd so are you interested in becoming a
business analyst but unsure where to
start simply lens Masters program and
business analyst can help you gain the
skills and experience you need to
succeed in the dynamic field this
program is designed to provide a
comprehensive understanding of business
analysis including data analysis
business process modeling and project
management the program is delivered
through a combination of online courses
live instructor-led classes and Hands-On
projects you will have the opportunity
to work on real-world business problems
and gain practical experience that will
be invaluable in your career this
program is also designed to help you
prepare for industry certifications
including the certified business
analysis professional cbap and the entry
certificate in business analysis ecba so
if you are ready to take your career to
the next level and become a business
analyst and online simply let's Masters
program on business analyst today with
simply learn you can learn anytime
anywhere and at your own pace without
any further Ado let's look at the agenda
for this video we will begin with
discovering business analyst job title
and exactly what are its roles and
responsibilities then we will discuss
what kind of surgery you can expect from
this kind of job then we will discuss
some essential steps you need to follow
to become a business analyst finally
we'll look at how a business analyst job
impacts different Industries so who is a
business analyst a business analyst is a
professional who analyzes annual its
business processes identify programs and
opportunities and develop solutions to
help organizations meet their objectives
they work closely with stakeholders to
understand their needs and requirements
and ensure that business goals are met
now let's check out their roles and
responsibilities the roles and
responsibilities of a business analyst
can vary depending on the organization
and Industry however some common
responsibilities include gathering and
analyzing data creating reports and
presentations identifying opportunities
for process Improvement and community
getting with stakeholders to become a
business analyst you will need to have a
strong analytical skills excellent
communication skills and a deep
understanding of business processes you
will also need to be comfortable working
with data and using analytical tools
next let's discuss three necessary steps
you need to take to become business
analyst the first step is to gain the
necessary skills like analytical problem
solving communication Technical and
Leadership skills Etc a degree in
business or a related field can be
helpful but it is not always necessary
many business analysts come from diverse
backgrounds including engineering
economics and computer science you can
also gain experience by working on
projects and internships this will give
you the opportunity to work with
business analysts and learn from their
experiences you can also attend
conferences and workshops to gain
further knowledge and network with other
Professionals in the field once you have
gained the necessary skills and
experience it's time to start looking
for a job you can search for business
analyst positions on Joe forums like
Glassdoor indeed Etc or or you can have
a look at company websites like Amazon
that has a career section on its website
you can also reach out to recruitment
agencies and staffing firms during the
interview process be prepared to discuss
your experience and how you can
contribute to the organization be
confident and articulate and show that
you are a good listener and Problem
Solver finally once you have landed a
job as a business analyst continue to
learn and grow attend conferences and
workshops read industry Publications and
network with other Professionals in the
field you can take up a few online
courses to gain new skills you can check
out our postgraduate program in business
analysis you can find the link in the
description box and there you have it
those are the essential steps to
becoming a successful business analyst
remember it takes time and effort to
develop the necessary skills and gain
experience but you can achieve your
goals with persistence and hard work now
you may ask how much salary you can
expect for a joke as a business analyst
the average salary for a business
analyst in the US is around fifty seven
thousand dollars to hundred thousand
dollars per year with some earning
hundred thousand foreign depending on
their experience and Industry in India
the average salary for a business
analyst is around 8 lakhs to 17 lakhs
per year again depending on experience
and Industry next we have the roles of a
business analyst in different fields
business analyst job can come from many
Industries let's go over them one by one
firstly let's talk about Finance
industry business analysts working in
finance might focus on identifying new
investment opportunities analyzing
financial data or developing strategies
for risk management they play a crucial
role in helping companies make informed
financial decisions by providing
valuable insights into Market prints and
opportunities in the healthcare industry
business analysts might work to improve
operational efficiency identify
opportunities for cost savings or
analyze patient data to identify Trends
and inform medical decisions they might
also collaborate with doctors and nurses
to develop and Implement new processes
that improve patient outcomes business
analysts in the IT industry are often
responsible for identifying
opportunities for process Improvement
developing requirements for software
developing projects or analyzing data to
inform website design and user
experience they play an essential role
in ensuring that technology initiatives
align with business objectives and
provide value to end users in the
marketing industry business analysts
might work to identify new Target
audiences analyze campaign data to
inform future marketing strategies or
develop metrics to measure the success
of marketing initiatives they help
companies better understand their
customers and make data-driven decisions
that improve the effectiveness of the
marketing efforts in the detail industry
business analysts might work to identify
Trends in consumer Behavior develop
pricing strategies or analyze inventory
data to improve supply chain efficiency
they play an essential role in helping
companies stay competitive by
identifying areas for improvement and
implementing strategies to address them
finally in a consulting firm business
analyst might work with clients across
various Industries to identify
Improvement areas develop growth
strategies or conduct market research to
inform decision making they provide
valuable insights and recommendations to
help clients achieve their goals and
succeed in their respective Industries
business analysts are essential to many
different Industries and can
significantly impact a complete success
their core responsibilities typically
involve identifying business problems
and opportunities gathering and
analyzing data developing requirements
and strategies and communicating with
stakeholders and that's it for the video
I hope this video helped you on your
journey to become a business analyst if
you like this video and want more such
videos then hit that like button and
subscribe to our YouTube channel and if
you have any questions let us know in
the comment section below until next
time stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
thank you